you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying gang
buzz bug
sure
one time when i was a kid i was with my
brother and we were [ __ ] roughhousing
i mean i had to be [ __ ]
my god he must have been
rough but
you guys because it sounds like rough
houses means like looking at each other
and blinking dude all
or not
so we're roughhousing okay and then now
it's starting to sound like a [ __ ]
german thing roofhousing um so
so uh so i stand up and i i when we were
really young and uh um i
i went to go
take my my penis out to [ __ ]
pretend to piss on him and i said i'm
gonna pee in your mouth dude oh and he
goes like this and he goes like this no
and
you know like
when you do a pump fake when you're
going to punch someone you get him to
flinch you do that with your wiener i
did that with my piss but i didn't i was
too young enough to realize if i pump
fake with the piss the piss isn't going
to come back
so i let it fly and he goes no and it
goes no
right in his mouth and he goes out and
he ran downstairs to my mom
and i was gonna get so much trouble so i
literally thought in my head i was like
chris now's the time just be more
believable than matt and he ran down to
the [ __ ] kitchen he said mom chris
pissed in my mouth and i [ __ ] very
confidently said no i didn't that's
[ __ ] ridiculous and my mom you says
matthew don't make up lies like that
dude i remember you
i remember in school one time i don't
know if i'm impressed with you or
disappointing your mom some kid fought
me at school one time right david koresh
and he won i remember that he beat your
ass no he didn't beat my ass but he hit
me first i was and then i just like
closed my eyes and swung a couple times
you know
so i i think in hindsight i kind of made
it more challenging on myself which i
think was that part was cool but i
didn't know if i hit him or not but
anyway we had to go downstairs to the
principal
uh
and
the lady
the principal said
um
oh she's like you guys are in trouble
for fighting right
and i said uh
and i took control i was like no what
happened was a couple of kids attacked
us
oh and you got out of it and there was
no communication really between the the
teacher that sent us down and the
principle
so i was like he and i just got caught
in each other's crossfire a little bit a
couple kids attacked us maybe gay kids
or whatever right like we were tango and
cash together so we had to defend
ourselves
and they let it they were like okay i'll
just give you guys the gift you become
friends after that huh did you become
friends after that that's honestly
that's how the video game double dragon
came about
i respect him
what's he do now uh cop oh yeah
so you went opposite ways full circle
he's a cop now he's protecting me yeah
no well he's actually not protecting you
though right where what city is he in i
used to have dreams and he that he threw
a blanket out when i was in a fire he's
in covington louisiana oh okay i said
dreams that he threw a blanket on me
after i was in a fire
you still have those dreams uh-uh i had
a dream last night where i [ __ ] was
dr i bought an 18-wheeler and i [ __ ]
uh was driving it and it and it rolled
and i had made it roll and i had to
[ __ ] get it repaired and it was 150
grand those are my dreams oh brandon
likes roles
[Laughter]
i can't remember the last time i had a
dream huh
that's because you're drinking too much
and so it is scary you're drinking too
much and something's wrong with your
brain it's the king and the sting back
up in this thing i just got a call that
said they wanna have the wing they got
me working ot all night long how many
times i gotta make this song